won't you H to
sin these songs are
Freedom cuz all I
[Music]
ever Redemption
Song when you write
that all my
[Applause]
life are you ready for
Marley and
the don't let them fool you that's a hit
is the people
music you know you're a
superstar iin a
superstar you can't separate the music
and the
message you see reg music com for unify
the people not Everyone likes what
you're saying for your own s safety you
need to
[Music]
stop on December 3rd 1976 would be
assassins invaded Bob Marley's home and
attempted to take the life of the singer
wife don't worry about that don't
worry every little going to be all right
you like that
yeah there's a war going on oh I can't
bring peace I can't even get peace from
me R
upile
[Music]
withing little
bird
sometimes the messenger has to become
the
[Music]
message
Bob I know it's
dangerous but you're the only one who
can unite the
people you're ready
B no guns can stop this
[Music]
message I want the World to
Change and that time is no
[Applause]
about this is my message to
you